hey how's it going we're going to start
yeah I'm Dalton I'm a partner of Y
Combinator and we're gonna do in office
hours today yeah yeah a couple things to
know I know that a couple of live office
hours happened beforehand we're going to
try to spend a little bit of time even
after these two talk with the different
companies 20 minutes for office hours is
not a normal time prayer that we'll do
stuff so we're going to try to do it as
fast as possible apologies in advance we
might interrupt you just because we know
how short the time is to try to get as
much information out of you or as
communicate as well all right thanks for
looking yeah hi done Kevin Kerry yeah I
ate it all how's it going and then I
think you'll need to use the mic right
yeah they handle mic yeah so just very
quickly introduce to eat yourselves like
your name your role as a company and
then name of the company and what you
guys are doing yeah I'm sure T we're
with Hobhouse Kerry and I'm the CTO
video and then what is how positive so
how fast is coal living we provide
co-living spaces for professionals so if
you're new to the area you've just
you've just gotten here and you want to
rent a room out in a house with a
curated community and you want to be set
up you can move into one of our rooms
and then what is Co living exactly me :
means living with the group of people so
basically shared housing how many people
our houses are five to ten people some
coal living spaces can range up to 30
foot hours or five to ten and then is it
it's a characteristic that you're
sharing a bathroom with a bunch of other
people also I was going thoroughly some
are some don't got chance and then how
are things going for you guys so far
pretty well so we launched 18 months ago
we are now at 220 tenancies across over
a dozen cities in the Bay Area in Los
Angeles
what's the occupancy rate so we
currently have occupancy rate of 94%
most of the vacancy rate comes from our
launched vacancy so our vacancy rate not
including the first two weeks in the
last two weeks is about 2% 2%
so when you say 94% like how many people
doesn't mean like in 220 properties Oh
so I'm sorry so 220 tenants total
and sketches 220 yeah that includes so
that doesn't so that we have more work
than 220 live about engine 30 loons to a
bit the group so in terms of the
timeline when did you first start like
you say 18 months ago but what what did
that look like the very first intended I
guess yeah so first thing is we got a
house and I was actually we both still
live in our health houses but I moved
into our very first hub house and then
we got a bunch of tenants and the first
few houses was very much so a learning
process we're trying to figure out what
works what doesn't and try to create
this backbone for our for call living
spaces this is they took about seven it
about I think it's seven thousand at
those three months okay and so you guys
take on the lease what are the terms of
the lease that you take out it's just a
standard when you're at least then it
goes month month I see yeah so we do we
do one year to two year lease is for
each of our houses and we continue with
one or two you need any special
permissions from the actual owner of the
property to do this yes so we're
completely upfront with their owners we
don't know exactly what we're doing we
sell it as a benefit we act as a
property adviser to the owners and we
guarantee them rent every month you see
the house is completely baked it and
then what's the margins that you get
currently um thirty to forty percent
forty percent so let's just say let's
take a typical property about like one
house has how many rooms on average six
rooms and then how much are you paying
rent on that house
so roughly $6,000 accessible and then
you guys will make forty percent on top
of that usually renting out um so if I'm
a property owner why is this a good deal
you said an advisor I don't really know
what I mean like why am I like wow
please have a bunch of people coming to
my house and like maybe it's going to
depreciate a lot yeah so most of our
property owners have pretty large
properties which are hard to rent out so
we're able to quickly run out or a house
which maybe rents for like $6,000 to
$8,000 and instead of having to deal
with a typical roommate situation where
you have to deal with five like six but
the landlord doesn't care about that as
long as they get paid you know like this
is been going on a while the landlord is
like I don't care as long as the rent
shows up whatever you guys are doing no
problem well so the end of the day is a
landlord you want one check you want to
make sure your house is taken care of
and you want professional people living
there and you don't want to have to deal
with it so we take care of all the hard
stuff if there are any property problems
which come up we advise them on what to
do but at the end of the day all you're
getting is one check and you don't hear
anything from us so what's the rate of
growth so how are things going right now
you said you're doing pretty well both
like is revenue increasing monthly or
weekly yeah so over the so we just
raised around
and after we raised we've kind of scaled
back and even growing at our time I
would just go back aha we wanted to hire
a team we wanted to make sure our
processes were going well we will say we
were walking about like $80 with each of
us and we were kind of reaching the
limit of all we could do without a team
so just to go back so what is the rate
of growth right now about eight to ten
percent eight to ten percent alone yeah
and we're growing so before that we were
doing about the cost are you having on
your property is that pretty much your
bottleneck finding supplies right now
our our bottleneck is operations so we
want to make sure that each of our house
is launching smoothly and well so that's
that's what I know you don't have a
playbook for launching properties do you
have we have a forty property forty
properties and you feel like you saw why
do you feel like you don't have a
playbook after 40 I mean we definitely
we do have a playbook so we do have a
step-by-step process that we go through
but we've just gotten our team on and
we're building out our tech and training
so that we're able to scale sustainably
and provide a fantastic experience to
each customers so when you say you want
to build out a team to build techinique
just dig into that a little bit like
what do you need the team to do so we
don't have a team so before until
December I was the only full-time person
working and in December Kari came on
full-time Kari was working as a
co-founder before that buddy came on
full-time and then we had one employee
in December so the past few months we
hired on a property manager we hired on
a person to help out with partnerships
and we want a second developer to
basically help us build out the tech to
automate a lot of these manual processes
that we're doing such as like responding
to emails responding to tenants with
property management inquiries that come
in we want there's ways to automate a
lot of those steps we do look at
ourselves like a marketplace but it's
not a true marketplace because we're not
connecting delay
with the tenants and so we do have a
supply demand factors of it we found
that it tends to go back and forth
between us and I can continue and I
understand that I thought it's it's you
it's two it's two parts yeah so right
and you're connecting them together so I
don't
so the parents never deal with the
landlord specifically and so we're not
connecting landlords with the tenants we
have to make the deal with the land of
themselves right it's one ecosystem so I
want to go system again and you're
bringing them takeaway dialers of how
like the connections happen it sort of
thinks that it works that way what I'm
trying to figure out is how does this
sort of win and in the thing is like do
you feel like part of Co living is like
this movement like people are realizing
like I want to work and there's a lot
nicer if I can work with a bunch of
other people but the places where I
wonder I take it you mostly are in the
Bay Area right yeah when we're in the
Bay Area and LA then it's like really
expensive to get places and so for the
places where I'm trying to get in there
really quickly I might not have enough
capital to move in so the co living is a
way to like step into that so trying to
think is like do you have a reliable
source of supply for people for this
like it's let's say this isn't really
big trends that you're going to be able
to on board and I'm trying to figure out
is like at what point do you feel like
you fought ready to battle new
properties and what rate do you add on
property so we're picking up
approximately four to six houses a month
four to six a month yeah okay and then
you put and then how long are they
vacant before like how long is needed to
get a house up and going so the time
from when we sign a lease to the time
the first person moves in is about two
weeks the time from when we launch the
house when it's 100% full is another two
weeks so about a month before it's a
completely I've been running house so
we've seen a lot of people work on this
idea and it seems like you can get about
as far as you have gotten which is
really great
but to because you actually have to take
on the lease and because you have hard
costs sometimes these can look much more
like a real estate business than a tech
business and so I think
what what I kind of want to get at is
are there ways that you can not hold the
leases like is there a way you can make
this much more efficient from a capital
basis because right now this is
basically a real estate business right
and it sounds like there's some tech in
there but I haven't really gotten from
you the tech is like the differentiating
factor that will make like that it
sounds like it's a lot of operations
work to sign leases and then get people
in units which is like pretty
traditional residential housing type
business so how are you thinking about
what what lets us get huge right like
what are your thoughts on long rows
lines so out of it so there is a good
deal of tech I do agree that it is not
the key differentiating factors that we
have some of its different and we
automate a lot of the operations that
all happening what are those is for like
hey the faucet is broken can someone fix
it and you open a ticket is that what
you mean like can you somebody was still
more along the lines of automatically
finding houses to go and see using some
different methods they'll automatically
posting and so we have a constant in
stream of probably about 100 tenants
reaching out to us a day that's really
automated by tech a lot of the intro
operations going between that is
operated by tech none of that's very
some of its you need some of it's not so
much unique I'd say the bigger
differentiating factor which we have
imagined yet is the community fact that
we build into it which is a lot of
people come because it's cheaper and
because it's a place that they need
quickly but we have a very strong
community element and create an
infrastructure in each house so people
are actually forming this really strong
bond how do you make that happen so part
of that is we set up monthly dinners and
we give them full match of these are
things you should go over and we throw
events every month for the entire
community
and so we're actually connecting these
people and for that reason we've had a
continual growth while we started with
month-to-month leases we've moved up
since then our average state length has
been a continual process upwards since
the beginning so going quite honestly I
feel like this really comes down to cost
like people want to move into cities in
places where it's highly desirable but
property is like non abundant and then
trying to figure out how can I get to
this on a cost affordable way
so co-living goes a way to sort of make
it happen you can advertise all these
community stuff it's stuff that you can
sell to people but it's no different
from an apartment a condo complex is
like a we have these smoothies up we
have a pool room we have things like
what they dinners or barbecues like it
doesn't sound any different because no
one says like we don't have a community
here we don't do anything nice for the
people make sure there's a bunch of
shitty people here living inside of it
you don't sound any differentiated from
it so all I can think it's like this is
pretty much it's as a land grab if you
have more great properties than anyone
else and then like onboarding feels so
simple and easy basically it's like
someone contacts you on average home
before they move down at a month no so I
mean it's a short as a week or two but I
think the difference is a thousand
access to rooms isn't easily accessible
right now access to rooms in
single-family homes with curated
communities the only way you can get
access to these is through Craigslist or
by setting it up yourself so we're
unlocking a whole new market which is a
build a brand it's young it's a dead
house is still of thing robbed of its
key anybody dead houses and living a
dead house yeah okay cool yeah okay so
clearly there's people that want to do
this and okay so it sounds like what
about five minutes left so what one of
the things you're thinking about that
can make this as constructive as
possible because like you know just to
summarize sounds good
you're making money like good job what
might be tough is what's the move to
make this huge let me give you some
options sometimes people that are
working on the startup idea decide to
actually buy the properties because you
can renovate them and then you actually
own an asset and it becomes almost again
like a real estate business and I've
seen that's kind of the we work model
right so I've seen that happen on the
other hand you can try to make this as
asset light possible or maybe you're not
taking the obligation of the leases
right and then you can grow really fast
and somehow have a special duo of the
landlords where you can just like grow
really fast and then you're a true
marketplace because you're not holding
any the liability that right now you're
holding or you can again maybe you found
the just right compromise between the
two so this is sort of work I would
think about from from the long-term
perspective
do you have thoughts around where you
see this going in a year or two so the
latter is probably the direction we're
going to go the reason why we have it is
because it hasn't really been a problem
until now
but in the future as it does become more
of a problem we do want to shift more of
the liability to the
property owners got it and one quick
question where on that is there any
insurance implications to this yep what
kind of insurance you have to take out
so we do have a pretty comprehensive
insurance policy to cover our properties
if our tenants to damage anything up to
like if the ten is burned down the house
or something they are covered and then
we are also asking our tenants to get
renters insurance on top of that if your
problem right now is like operation that
you're recruiting trying to find people
like what is your pitch to people to get
people on board that they like to come
and do this startup because not many
people are dream to be like I'm going to
work on basically the new form of like
apartment complexes or dorms basically
get dorms for like Millennials I mean so
I think the biggest piece of our company
is our community so each of our house is
almost like a family like environment
and people can really buy into that I
mean I think a lot of people out here
don't really have access to that and
around universities sure some people
have access to things like debt houses
but most people out here move out here
and are lonely and don't really know
people so being able to offer the sense
of community and the friendships that
form from within our community is
probably the biggest pitch that we make
and so you think that's the that's the
long-term defensibility thing is
ultimately community I'm just rying to
make sure I understand so you're saying
like look we're going to have the best
community the best Brantford community
and that's what will attract people
because again with this kind of business
it's very easy for new entrants to come
in so if we use the example of Airbnb
anyone can make it early and be clone
but what they actually had it was
Network effects we're just like eBay
it's hard to clear an eBay because they
have the buyers and sellers what's the
equivalent here it is the community so
you're saying so it is branding a lot of
that and we do have a network effect B
it is not just a community in the houses
we connect all the houses to each other
as well so we do have a bit of a network
effect there okay I do think branding is
a defensibility pote the other key part
that shooties mentioned to me in the
past is most of the competitors can do
102 things well so campus was a previous
company who did very something very
similar but they had very low motion on
it and they did the community aspect
really well people love staying in them
but the operations was awful and then
there's other companies that do the
operations very very well but and many
people have come to us and said
everybody talked about community but
you're the only ones with it and so we
feel that what we have is different but
we are also good at operation
and so that's the post that we are
trying to scale and try and a high of
attack to moto name mode mode into a
tech business and to take all the the
lengthy processes that all taking
operations like we're hiring for more
engineers right now and making that
automate as possible so we can do less
of the actual designing releases and the
direct things there I think on the
community stuff for good it's tough for
you to focus on it will prevent term
from happening but for the conversion my
feeling is your bond unlike is probably
still supplies so whatever it is you
need to do to relieve yourself on like
what allows us to say we want to take on
more properties because really what your
setup is like your liability is that
first month's rent that you may take on
that's like your which is pretty decent
source casa like it so if you can figure
out like how can I turn around where
like I sign a house right and I can turn
around I I think you also have to put
safety like a security deposit also so
it's almost two months worth of rent but
that you're taking on before you can
have it covered back and how long before
you have that come just about a month
about a month so it's going to be about
two it's maybe about four months before
you cover both of it before cover two
months worth of rent well we collect
back security deposits from our tenants
oh great and then I think that I think
that's all it comes down to like you
need to figure out how to do all the
community stuff ahead of time but
everything that allows you to say like I
want to take as many properties as
possible I figure out how to jumpstart
them um and like get people into the
houses their homes very very quickly
without losing quality and so the whole
thing is like what is that exact play
book like and you want to almost timers
off it's like okay we identified your
property how long does it take what is
our checklist that's very very level for
us to determine if it's viable or not go
in there figured out and that's where
part of the tech is going to be seeing
like how much can we do online and then
the second part of is going to be like
we send with someone down there they do
a very quick assessment and you have the
team that quickly turns around the place
to take the pictures put put the listing
up there and gets it out to people so
that's like the first supply and then
your demand is just like being very
proactive on getting the demand so that
a lot of the people tenants like you get
like testimonials you send it out to
whatever universities of wherever people
would be looking for housing is to make
sure that they all think like Hobhouse
is the first place I go
consider moving to a new cities like I
want help has to be there because I know
that's a good even if it's transit doors
like I wouldn't go there I'll be there
for maybe one to two months and then
I'll maybe on turns into something
better or some percentage and say like I
just want to stay here because the kind
of completely I want to be with imagine
most people are going she graduate
nobody wants to live in a coding forever
some people might but that's actually I
think the thing I'm most worried about :
kind of like co-working spaces something
I always get nervous about in terms of
brand erosion is that it's not an easy
way to like turn people out and the
thing is like in places where you go
where great people will graduate what
ends up being is like it slowly starts
rotting with people who like can't leave
if it's like I don't have anyone else
that loves me enough we want to live
with me or and it looks like online
forums it looks like coworkers it is
just like people don't want to be in
those spaces in or because it's like
held up with people who like never left
and they start kin grumpy cetera et
cetera but what you want to really pay
attention is like how do I figure that
out like how do I make sure that this
stays fresh how do I make sure that like
people who might be creating rot will
not like for like always on the rest of
the house yeah it's a paraphrase these
kinds of businesses churn kills you and
the founders never realized that they
have high churn until like you may be
like oh we're really great cheering
everyone says that but like and you
don't you don't have enough data yet but
over the long run sometimes you can
things can creep up on you and if all of
a sudden you start to have high turn and
then you're on the hook for all these
leases like these can get tricky this is
a lot of the food delivery type startups
like there's a whole class of things
that don't work and they're like we have
positive margins and we have low churn
and we have great like they all say the
same things but if you really dig into
them the the secret hiding in their
numbers that the founders don't want to
admit to themselves is that actually
churn can get you and if you have hard
cause like warehouses I did not for you
but for other people if you have all
these hard costs and then you have like
some down months like you have to pay
your rent every month you can't get out
of it I guess community is everything
yeah then the tools you want to think
about also are like the equivalent of
what you might see in like moderation
tools like
what like we have to build all this
stuff to work work on communities at
scale how does that work for like within
homes and houses like who do we have to
empower within our community to make
them sort of working carry things aren't
words lots of great real-life
communities that have grown to be really
big they actually be really careful like
how they sort of sets about so there's
going to delegate balance between that
you're actually going through right now
between like I need to achieve growth
and revenue but also need to make sure
the community is like taken care of and
so like the moment I think you choose
this way above this then then there's
the sacrifice but the thing is you have
to figure out like how do I get used to
work attendance in a way that doesn't
break everything and hopefully this
trend and this is the other thing I
always worry about is that this is a
trend that just might break over time
like just people cities and governments
are building enough housing that
basically people are able to find cheap
housing on their own they just live by
themselves from your perspective what do
you think the biggest risk is like what
do you is it is it you need a higher
Operations feel you know I'm saying like
what do you think is the like the idea
in the futures they didn't work here
like man it was this reason if you had
to get what do you think that is we
definitely do run a risk that if the
market crashes rents could just crash
and we are locked into one to cheerier
leases which is why we try to restrict
it to one to two year leases yeah I
think that's a big one can you think of
other - yeah I think I would agree that
that's the number one risk the other
quote is not being able to out be able
to continue to scale because operations
cost are not able to be automated in a
valid way yeah and like for your own
edification I think a good thing to do
would be to amortize all of your costs
for operations and your time when you're
calculating your margins this is a this
is a classic thing people do it's like
we do food delivery and we have positive
margins and it's it's just that they
sell you know a burrito for ten bucks
and it costs um seven bucks to make it
but if you include delivery costs if you
include support costs we include returns
if you like you actually bacon all this
stuff they are definitely not possible
project and so I think in your case just
for your own notification try to bake in
some of these costs you have from an
operating major eighty hours yeah you
got that on put those into them
you're merging calculation you know and
that will just help you know that you
actually building a great business
versus you're just like leaving out some
of the cost it's fine your margin
calculation yeah we're out of time thank
you so much thanks bye thank you
appreciate it thank you thank you thank
you hi hi good how are you guys good
okay so what's your name my name is Josh
all right Josh Shay hi Shay good nice of
you so we are lambda intelligence I'm
CEO and we built an API that allows
developers to extract product
information out of digit dish size
receipts so image receipt images and
turns out it's there's huge volumes of
data that's locked up in these before
you go into your backstory can you be
really clear so who is the customer so
we're actually selling two mobile app
developers so we've got a mobile app
developer who's who we just signed a
contract with that our first customer
but they're paying us two thousand bucks
a month right now for processing um
basically product information out of
receipt images okay so you guys offer
you an API to be able to take receipt
and just like give infrastructure
information exactly I mean can you give
me one more use case like why is this
developer need this so the the course
piece here is not just the the OCR but
it's also mapping the shortened product
descriptions and and the prices to the
actual product the full product name
description brand all that type of
structured information so but what is
their app to so like why would I want to
download their app what do I get to do
it so they're a loyalty card vendor yeah
so they're using this to better their
app and better target themselves to
their customers so that's why they need
this product information I always get
nervous with API companies because
basically API is like the bottom rung
dense infrastructure for like software
projects and so like they tend to want
to be like commodities ultimately in the
and and and so the great API companies
are going to be like okay if we're going
to be figure out I do this as cheaply as
also because it's going to better become
a commodity then like rich ones are
going after markets that are super super
huge so that's what I'm very interested
in with the customers you're like mobile
app developers that need to read
receipts
how many of those are there so you could
system that's that's actually a good
question there are only 200 mobile app
developers but the second side of the
business that we are focusing on that
brands are really interested deeply
interested in this type of data so we're
in talks with one of the top brands with
class and they've expressed interest in
getting this type of data from us so
okay so a real customer is CPG company
exactly but yeah you need to okay so you
have like a multi-step process you're
like are you giving the API away for
free no no I why not just give it for
free if the real customers are mean
giant CPG companies why not to do like
mobile app developers we have a really
great like OCR receipt reading things
have added and then because you have the
best data collecting up all that
information then you're able to actually
close Enterprise that that's kind of our
plan going forward right now we're able
to get some revenue off of just
providing this OCR API to our mobile app
vendors and so that's kind of our way of
bootstrapping I think it would just slow
you down the thing is like how
bootstrapped are you like are you going
to run out of money we are completely
bootstrap right now yeah and right now
they're paying us $2,000 per month for
processing their receipts this is on
track to scale up to 59 and sorry just
like you process the receipts like what
are you what do you point out of the
receipt the product data be like why do
they why they giving you that's like a
lot of money for an app developer to
give you like why are they what is the
thing that they can't build themselves
that you can build it's like super
useful to them so the theme that we got
is that we've built a bunch of scrapers
and we've got some partnerships in were
they email risky are you scraping or
email are you going - what do you
scraping exactly we're scraping receipt
images so like people days or elbows
okay the users are iffy photographs
visible receipt yep
that the app developer calls your API
would would eat it like a gift yeah and
then like you OCR and you're like okay
this is what this thing says yeah it was
a structure it for them
okay so that it's it's not just the the
receiving these accounts to do loyalty
okay so I'm just making sure I really
understand exactly right the ideas okay
yes you get it yeah I do get it just
makes you nervous because what if your
real customer is a CPG it's like what
you wrote this is one of like how much
data do you need to collect or craft to
say like we'll even look at this so I
know it's got to be a lot yes they want
a million receipts a month gotcha
so all the mobile app developers that
potentially need how much so much can
accurate the people who mostly vit
attract receipt 70 people were tracking
expenses it's the only enough I use that
I take a picture of my receive nothing
consumer related do I do that and
there's loyalty stuff but but going
along this line of thinking so if your
real customer is a CPG and this is sort
of everyone can extrapolate from this on
the audience but like maybe you should
just be building the receipt tracking
app that does loyalty like it seems like
you're trying to use this API thing is
like like a shortcut and like it's going
to be hard but you're like well we don't
really know how to get a million
receipts so let's just pull an API and
well and like other people will get
receipts and like that kind of sounds
like wishful thinking unless and again
it's great that you have as first
customer so can you know congrats on
that but like to get a million receipts
today are they going to have a million
receipts so they're on track so they
want us to do about half a million
receipts right now so they're they're
getting us close but and so we'll need
to work with a couple others they're
actually processing that many they're
getting that many and so that's that's
the that's what I mean ok along this
line of thinking like and they're cool
with us right because sometimes was
tough with an API company is if you're
doing something and that is really
straightforward how you're monetizing it
to people like you're kind of a
middleman and like eventually people
like to squeeze out middlemen right and
so maybe they're like hey this is really
valuable maybe they're maybe the app
that you're selling an API to also wants
to sell us the CPGs did you see the
tension there yeah yeah yeah we see that
and actually we've done research and
CPGs are buying lots of the
from third-party companies like Oracle
data logic spewing and they're spending
millions of dollars to get this type of
data and what's interesting is that this
data is more aggregated in nature that
it's mostly transactional and what we
are getting at is like product level
data that we are focusing on which we
know like brands really want so that
makes sense
but I think just from a scale
perspective like my understanding of
what data brokers want for ad targeting
is like tens of millions or hundreds
like the scale that you need to build a
data business is much larger like have
you seen anyone even with millions like
maybe some millions that gives you the
mostest ones I've seen that people doing
this is like they're offering companies
are free so grocery stores electronics
stores retailers thanks you for free Eve
receipts they say like we offer this
technology your seats for free and then
what they do is they take all the data
and what they have is like it's good for
those customers it's good for the
retailers because they're getting
information they wouldn't have otherwise
about them their customer base and then
they resell the data the data player the
CPG and like even bigger retailers and
so the whole thing it's race to the data
so it feels like oh I closed this
company they're doing a half a million
receipts well ok maybe this is easier
than that thing then like what's the
barrier for you closing more people
right and I think that's that's
something that we're actively trying to
to go after more of these kind of data
sources and so the more data sources
that we can get obviously that then
improves the value of our yeah yeah so
how's that how's that going like I did
he said there's like 200 so I've emailed
all 200 so we've emailed about a hundred
of them so far and what do you learn
we've learned so we our response rate
has been about 25 percent so far and
we've learned that the current mobile
app window that's providing us this data
like I like them others are also
interested and they are willing to share
the data because they are experiencing
similar problems they have always did
you you had 25 people respond to you why
are they not customers that's actually
the question so interesting only
launched our private data was with this
small black thunder about
a week and a half ago so we're still
super early on this and so we've got a
we've got like a list of meetings like
next week and so one of the reasons why
they're not customers yet is because our
sales cycle is a little bit I think
probably at least a month or two it's
still pretty good yeah but I mean these
aren't really under price prices at your
target right okay I think Friday P is
like the biggest thing is like for any
of you guys like you have such a long
cycle because you gotta me with like
someone on the CTA you have to have
someone actually try to saying are
people going to be invested and is it
meeting at the right time right so it's
like at the time that someone's devolved
in the app and need to work on the
feature is at the time that they sort of
needs your product or service so it's
really a matter of like you need like
all cylinders going up once to have as
many of those people try because you
don't know at what point that all of a
sudden there's a proper nexus of the
sale to actually close or usage to
actually happen when you talk is like
crass how much we really they willing to
pay so they were looking at 20 cents of
receipts
yeah yeah okay so so one thing this is
just like a general purpose piece of
advice is like when you're dealing with
large corporates um they employ lots of
people in the business development role
and their job is to meet with people and
to find innovative stuff all the time
and for every deal that they actually do
and for every you know contract they
execute they probably meet with 100
startups and so we meet with a lot of
startups all the time that have similar
things where from from their side of the
table you just ask for something crazy
like go get a million receipts and then
we'll look at it and maybe we'll pay but
you know they I doubt they're saying on
it writing right did they send you a
contract no okay well so like you can
give people these impossible tasks just
like for fun and see if they come back
with it but even if they do come back
with it that doesn't necessarily mean
they're going to do the deal with you
and so we're always talking to startups
that they believe the best case scenario
and that's such it's so good to be
optimistic so I get why but they believe
the best case scenario that you know hey
this huge fortune 500 company is going
to do a deal with my two-person startup
and they're going to give us a million
dollars and man does that rarely like
usually to pattern match here usually
you have to
err step up and you start with smaller
customers that say yes more quickly and
it's for smaller dollar amounts and you
have to do that for quite a while before
able to get one of these deals you can
sometimes people call them Silver Bullet
deals you know it's like a deal that
makes your startup where you go from
zero revenue to a million somehow the
universe makes those very those things
rarely happen and so I think in your
case what one one negotiation tactic
here maybe is to be like hey like we
don't have a million receipts but why
don't we start with a pilot we do have
whatever half a million how about that
let's start with that in like let's just
get this going and let's do our first
day to drop and let's get this on paper
and what you can do when you're
negotiating these kinds of people is to
try to like if they're saying come back
with this really hard thing and then
maybe I'll say yes get move them down to
something you can do something that's
more minor and then try to get it in
writing and once you get something in
writing it's so much more likely they'll
do the deal because talk is cheap man
like anyone could say Oh we'll give you
a million dollars if you do whatever but
to get someone that works at a
corporation to put some in a paper
they're either in a couple of excuse why
they can't or they're actually serious
and think about how much better that
would be for you as founders if you had
some into writing because then you know
this is real and that can give you so
much more confidence that you're going
down the right direction so that that's
always something I would suggest this
does for everybody that we are dealing
with these big organizations let's try
to get anything to write five minutes
the thing I don't like about this kinda
code it's inefficient like one you're
working on like commodity level data
processing this being set up and then
you have to do one thing before you can
do the other thing alright and it's a
two-step process and so there's like
there's mold there's so many additional
risk so to me it's always like alright
I'm trying to get this other thing how
do I make that go really really fast
to prove out this sort of nature so
that's why my first thing is like just
make this freight like it's like it's
your mobile developers really want this
and everything comes down to like you
having as much data as possible and you
make sure that you get as much data as
possible as quickly as possible and that
means like
giving it doing it and doing it at a
scale that other people won't be able to
sort of compete because I I firmly
believe like down the line like you this
technology for OCR processing for like
receipts is of like that's going to be
fairly common maybe this is a dumb
question but is there a reason why I
like Expensify and all the receipt
tracking things aren't just doing this
like why aren't they why can't the CPG
to get access to all these other receipt
tracking data things I mean we've seen
so far is that a lot of the accuracy
levels in receipts is still pretty low
interesting and like especially because
you can get at the the direct OCR that
that's pretty good at this point but
it's going from that OCR kind of piece
to an NLP piece that that a lot of
companies either are really good at you
actually need to skew is that what
you're saying like yes is that they
don't they can get pricing date but they
don't have the actual skew to map it
back exactly because that's exactly what
it is okay and it I mean it's it's one
of those things like this is a problem
that I actually solved and when I was a
co-founder at a healthcare company we
had lab forts that we actually had to
match to like individual sno-med lab
codes and so I did that there and so we
were able to do it for 40 million
patients that's great so here's
something to think about when you're at
this stage is like you think about what
are my strengths what are the things
that we can do really well that no one
else can do and what are the areas where
we're on the same level playing field
with everybody else and so I feel like
what I'm getting from this conversation
is that a lot of your strength is in
this technology and it is in the fact
you can build this amazing OCR and it
sounds like you've been trying to find
what the best possible market is and so
by doing a bunch of customer
conversations right you ended up saying
hey you know what cpgs have money and we
can use this technology we already know
we're good at and so I would think of
your core strengths as being the
technology now that CPG side until you
have your first thing in writing that's
still in the question mark it's not not
a strength but you don't it's not like
in the bag in the way that it sounds
like you have a technology networks
today right yeah yeah that's on the bag
like you can take that to the bank and
so I would think about you know thinking
about what your strengths are and then
maybe being open minded to how you
monetize it
because it could be you know until you
get this right until you lock in this
risk that this may not be the best
possible market for this technology we
call being promiscuous yes the open mind
in two ways you can use this like other
people may be like hey you don't need a
million receipts we'll give you money
today for this other like semi-related
like it could be really close to what
you're doing in or could be a little
farther away we don't know but you have
something really special and you have
how long ago did you talk to craft so we
talked to craft about three weeks ago
great
so you and then it's a deal closed with
a half a million no we are in relatively
early conversations but the shows iam
with crop with now that's what have you
opposed with the app developers yes the
deal is closed do you have data for half
a million yes it looks awesome okay you
should go immediately back the craft is
like we currently have let's do a pirate
half a million right would you vote was
interested in doing like a pilot oh you
know sign a letter intent says like you
know start looking at the data we
provided to you guys can check to see if
like is it what you're looking for
because that will help you know that
you're delivering on time and then like
I haven't found a letter Leonard's had
all just going to say it's just like
okay and then if we you know you're
going to initially look at this data to
help will work back and forth to see
like is this what you're looking for
this is going to be the format you want
and then when we have a million receipts
we'll start talking about pricing
because like again just put numbers on
this I would say when a start-up says
we're in discussions with a customer it
blows right on that is like 10 per site
is count to zero and easy way to rub you
between zero and ten percent it's very
low versus if you get an LOI then I
discount that to like fifty percent
because maybe even one six please
what's that 25 all right I guess I'm the
Rasta here but and then when you have a
signed contract and I'm just a herbicide
but like we from our side of the table
we've seen so many people that are in
discussions with all these great signing
deals and we're like what can you get
into writing and they're like then they
go try to get it right and they're like
nope
so that's such a good test at this stage
and it doesn't cost you anything
absolutely yeah the other piece advice
is I think Don talked about in terms of
like what you have in the bank in terms
of what you're good at
another way of thinking about it is that
like that is the default for your
business the default is for the
technology the OCR it has to work as
work better than anything else you have
to do this other thing you've seen a
startup that is going to actually
determine whether you'll grow and be
really successful or not is going to be
sales and so that is part you have to
work 10x harder on so this thing that
you're not very good at you actually
have to span ironically a lot more time
on it to make your company better and so
yes so the sales like you're going to
talk to all the rest of those mobile
developers try to get them all in
discussion and close them to get the
deal but also you've got crafts going on
but also you should talk to as many
other CPG companies also as well this
he's like is there a market beyond these
guys is it's the most sort of pricing
what do I need to understand what does
it needs to be delivered because I'm
actually you know basing everything that
I'm going to give the CPG companies on
what Crassus says so it's really like by
the end it's like the next like two
months it should be like you talk to if
you get how to talk to all the other
mobile developers and you talk to like
50 other CPG companies at the very least
that's almost all your time it's almost
no programming or coding it's just
developing the language for like do I
understand what is the process for
closing these deals which is actually to
make me money we're out of time guys
thank you so much thank you so much as
you thank you thank you thank you
hey that's good
I'm Dalton hi Kevin like hi cool so we
are working on comical a place where
people share and read short stories we
found a new format that's a little bit
like a picture book so there's a little
bit of text on each page then there's a
background image that relates to the
text and you tap through to flip through
the pages of the story people share
anything from poetry fiction as well as
random blog posts about what they're
doing in their daily lives
currently we get about a hundred
thousand monthly uniques and mostly
teenager is currently using I mean
students are being created twenty
thousand have been created total about
fifteen hundred months so let's say I'm
one of your active users what format do
I consume the same is this a mobile app
is a website right now with all mobile
web and you okay hundreds mo whoa okay
and what's the breakdown of what devices
they're on it's about half and half an
iOS and Android a decade 40 and then
what's the geolocation of those folks
what countries are they
it's like it's really leaning towards I
listen America and the rest of the world
Android so static 40 okay so so 60% iOS
us a full and then one of the countries
that are non-us emigration Philippines
is a pretty popular one okay UK okay
India and then what would be the
breakdown say of the Philippines on that
one like 10 20 percent to 15 percent 15
yes pretty much popular storyteller um
so there's a girl in LA and she
basically writes like kind of fourth
wall fiction stories and she already had
an audience before joining colorful and
she brought a good chunk of her audience
over gotcha and so like what is
popularly like does she have like you
guys have like a thing like subscribers
yeah so she has about 700 followers
that's so we had people have who have
more followers than her however she gets
the most likes on her stories kocchi
business hall condition publish probably
a couple times a month couple times
gotcha sorry like just I want to really
picture it so and then when she
publishes what is her me so there's a
few things people can make what is the
thing that she makes fiction stories how
long are they using they take about
three minutes to read and they're about
a thousand words
cool would you say there's any
similarity between this and some of the
apps that are like taking off right now
that are like collaborative fiction
what's the name of one of them there's
like Tommy yeah I've seen those right
there just if you squint at it at all
does it look like any of those it's a
very different model those are built as
games so there's a scripture
subscription model built into them
however we have very similar users so
many of the target users use both or you
know if they're conscious about the
money they use colorful so that's kind
of the yeah similar audience but
different do you have in app purchases
and you have anything analogous to that
currently no got it a little of
discipline okay I'm just trying to think
of how those companies work okay do you
see this and like how do you see what's
the big version of this like wow what's
the metaphor that you think of metaphor
wise we see this as kind of how these
teams interact with the written word so
you see Instagram and snapchat these as
these very very visual creatures very
short form types of content however the
written word really hasn't seen much
change and as a result a lot of the
stories that you can only tell through
the written war that you can't tell
through a snapchat or an Instagram
kind of get lost and for us we want to
be the bridge for this new generation to
the written word and those types of
stories these stories are like permanent
so they like at the exists in a space
are there same stories from like a year
ago they're still like super popular as
for the per minute question yeah um they
still it hits I wouldn't say they blow
up or they going to get us consistent
huge amounts of traffic but you know it
shows up on starts sometimes sometimes
it's still resurfaces and sharing and
Twitter if you have a sense of what
percentage of users come from SEO very
few it's we get like 700 clicks I think
per month what are the most consistent
sources of traffic like you said you're
it's the author's promote it so they
like post it to Twitter and Facebook and
they're not drive traffic it's pretty
much this is what success looks like to
me in this sort of space it really comes
down to is like you build a platform
that allows people to get famous it's
pretty much it and because like I think
there's like three drivers
three drivers of like desires by most
people and it's like money then like sex
and then like power or every women
right watch it's only three and so
without you so that so that influence is
like the biggest thing so like does your
platform a lot of people get really
popular do they generates up that lots
of people want to see and until you like
hit that the things that in the water so
this really it's like what do I do to
bring an on board the very best
storytellers bet very vegetable Anna
ideally it's like you guys are
constantly generating these servers and
they have to be really really great but
it also is like hopefully your
communities generating some and then are
you able to promote them better than
they can even promote themselves like
something has to happen there and that's
like your only goal like you can try to
monetize it cetera but I think it really
comes down to like it's just a platform
where it's like if I use this it's like
or I want to tell stories on here
because people actually read or
experience them it's like sometimes what
you saw more like media the whole thing
is like what do you do next I don't know
that's becomes really hard part
sometimes you end up raising a bunch of
money and doesn't work out but the whole
thing is you have to at least get to the
point where like it's a platform that
like gets people really popular so
everything has to do with like looking
at what is somewhat popular and saying
like how do I multiply that how do i
replicate that is there a while
portion of that where people see those
and they start making things um
themselves so it's like I would go and
just figure out like how do I get like
let me see here a best story I heard
from within the YC Katie was like twitch
like basically they launched during
platform and what they try to do is like
some people are already streaming gaming
on YouTube they contact all the top
streamers on there and said like what do
we have to do to get you to come to our
platform and then and they did whatever
they wanted like because they knew that
like if it's a power locker for content
right so only a handful of people going
to be the most popular and so like that
gives you the best head start and so
they built whatever features day by
super-nice them etc and so where are the
very best storytellers for your sort of
format and I would think it's like
creative people who have been really
good at chart or Instagram or whatever
and say like look you want more than
this
we can offer this to you I need to
figure out what do they most want and
then build those sort of features have
you started doing that yes so the last
while we've been sweet we know a lot of
top creators and that are the top
creative someone who has 10,000 50,000
hundred no only cool fine people
that are like the top one I think you
have to talk to them and figure out what
would it actually like the best only
authors the million followers plus could
you get could you start pulling people
off tumblr because tumblers that's
actually most of our traffic so when we
say before we go archaic like a business
because like grumbler Yahoo's not really
taken care of it and I imagine you can
pull like the top tumblr people right
yep so we're actually so we actually are
friends with all the top tumblr creators
yeah what we've been thinking about is
critical mass and we think that there's
a certain point like we want to spike
everything with all the users coming
together at once where you hit this
critical mass point and theoretically
you know five minutes I would not even
think of it like that that's like you
complicated it's mostly it's just like
all the popular kids and I'm just going
to systematically talk to a little and
grab get as many learning as you can and
you forget what you're looking for its
inspiration and you don't know what it's
going to be you don't know who's going
to be the one that like makes a platform
take off you don't know what there's a
piece that they're going to make so you
need just a lot of lightning striking
that's so hopefully like people go like
holy crap what's this new platform I
agree that I mean like look I think that
founders that are working on consumer
internet stuff under count how many
social things get to your scale and then
top out like they think everyone knows
the story of snapchat and Facebook and
they know about things like that but man
you know even back in the day there were
a lot of Facebook competitors like
hundreds right and a lot of them had
millions of users right right
tens of millions of users and I mean and
it the problem the thing the thing is
tricky about consumer internet if you're
not going to monetize you know by
charging your users if the only way you
can ever build and add business as you
need hundreds of millions and so I think
and you're like think about tumblr
itself they had trouble with their ad
business remember they were the winner
for every tumblr there were like 10
other little blog sites which it sounds
like you guys are expert so you remember
them right there were other in like one
of the tumblers that had decent you know
and why journalist all my journal was
original absurdity but like that if the
point of Naveen is I really Kevin if
you're going to do this kind of business
you usually want it to grow as fast as
you can and get those economies of scale
otherwise you can get stuck in the one
hundred thousand two million user range
and then like top out and then then what
like those are tough like that I know
the founders have a lot of those types
of ones and those are rough okay
I feel like you want both a bunch of
users and then a bunch of different
stories like I think again the approve
mixers like what are the top things that
people have done on tumbler recreating
it on your platform what are like top
tweet storms right that's like series of
like small pieces of tech and and then
we tell them on your pot and a sprays
twitch thing just tells ask them what
would it take for you to move everything
over from tumblr like what features do
we need to build for you to take
everything from your tumblr over here
and then put up a audios tumblr blog
post and then like point to your site
and then if you just did that
systematically that was that the twitch
playbook um hang out work I don't think
I think I think now is the time to raid
the twit the the tumblr users yeah yeah
one of the most popular things we have
is that it's a to direct my own thing so
if you haven't a context on tumblr and
then post it on comical and we have an
export function every social site has a
different like preferred format so on
tumblr we export as a photo set so if we
share in tumblr it automatic generator
fun stuff that's pretty and fish on
tumblr facebook is different twitter is
different you should also look at all
the people making the little stories on
medium 200 of them it's one okay
audibles to resume so like the whole
thing is i figure out talk to the top
storytellers positive to top people who
are on all those different platforms
figure out what it's going to take to
bring them all view or start moving some
of that stuff over automatically and
just show it showing it off to the
community everything like what sticks
what people really like what goes around
because like it oh consumer is different
like i think a lot of times people like
out in the audience world they they hear
these consumer things which is just get
fake if it get big and that is what
we're telling you but just for everyone
else aliens that's not the case if
you're doing like b2b and if you just
like like this is not like one size fits
all advice but like if you're going to
hey you're launched you're doing
consumer internet you have a hundred
thousand mau like okay like
you may get this part you've got a
you've got a like right power through
here that or else if you end up stalling
out on that in Milan then well and then
what like you're you don't have enough
users to really monetize and and that's
we've just seen a lot of people Scala at
this day so in your case yeah you get
you got to grow yeah are the position
here yeah well it just me you need to
generate whatever it takes to give
people the word of mouth about your
penis like oh I make it I'm a really
good creator I tell the stories on this
platform I can get really big and one of
the piece of tactical advice I would
look at SEO usually like the way you get
really huge
I built a consumer site I got it up to
25 million Mau and SEO was a big part of
that and the way you do something like
hora where you get hundreds of millions
of Mau is SEO so I would try to start
the time helps us get backlinks okay now
help us rank some of those storia that a
normally wouldn't almost yeah we're
posting SEO currently right now yeah
okay good that's what sort of thing it
doesn't cost you anything yet and
that'll just get the flywheel spinning
your you to hit that escape velocity
yeah five minutes any questions for us I
think this is the biggest challenge for
us obviously is getting from our hundred
thousand ten million right like this the
next big phase you've already kind of
gone over different strategies I'm
curious what other companies that you've
seen through going through YC who have
you know successfully gone from that
hundred thousand civilian it's the power
well it's always power law for those
kind of communities so the top ones
bring almost all the traffic which is
why I'm saying like everything you have
to do is like how do I bring on
celebrities onto the platform turn
people in this wolf and along those
lines here's the here's the pitfall
don't pay him right and you know pay up
sometimes I've seen people try that that
is not like hanging it paying for
traffic when you don't have revenue is
like they need to love it and what once
you pay them they also expect be pain
about it make something that is exactly
right like right like as far as my
understanding is you know Instagram
never paid anyone
snapchat never paid anyone all their
clones sure did right like but that's
you know understated like YouTube wasn't
really paying for traffic but although
want to be YouTube's that were trying to
raise money
paying for traffic so like whatever you
try don't just take what he's saying
yeah we're going to pay some celebrities
and you know it's not a cost-effective
way of grind yeah I think if you have
the dev cycles I don't know if you do
but I would consider a mobile app one
advantage from a retention perspective
is that you can do push notifications
yes and that way if someone is
subscribing to something and you do a
push notification to their followers
then you're ensuring a much more tighter
feedback loop then maybe you have now on
mobile web so as your email what are you
doing with email shows because their
team's email has been pretty tricky in
terms of editing or high response rates
we tried messenger BOTS so we get some
guesses response rate they're still
nothing huge or significant I would I
would keep explained with those again
you're asking what are people done you
have to reach out and touch people for
them to not forget your thing exists
like think about it like there's a
million apps out there there's a million
everything is competing for our
attention and if you think about tools
like Facebook it's basically a
weaponized attention grabber right they
have thousands of people working on
making sure that you're constantly
looking back at it right like very smart
people that's all they do all day is try
to like to steal your attention and
you're competing with them for attention
so I think just doing some really basic
stuff like continuing it around email if
chad is the right thing to do make sure
people remember you exist and that they
are a member of your community and that
they should go check out some new
stories otherwise it's going to be
tricky one experiment you could do I've
heard someone give this back before is
go create a Facebook account with like a
fake email and don't add any friends and
look at how many Gmail's it sends you I
staying on that it sends you like 50 I'm
exaggerating but the point is they
realize that if you don't add any
friends that you're going to have a bad
time and you're useless to them and so
they're very aggressive about emailing
people otherwise they know they know
they've turned you so anyway if you have
users that you know are gonna churn or
on the you know way past earning well
I'm just like remind them that you exist
that's the best practices to make up
Britain yeah guys thank you so much
thank you appreciate it
that's a lot six okay cool well I think
that's it for us